bien et benghazi où l'on interdit open
doors ce que vous préférez en vous ma
sérénité nouvelle on est obligé d'être
sérieux ah oui au sérieux enfin bien
obligé de dire la vérité bien sûr cergy
a dit toute la franchise qu'on a appris
qu'il était sado-maso chaque joueur
homosexuel et pire catalan est ce que
vous détestez en vous je suis un peu
maso ouais vous aussi bon mois ci ce qui
vous plaît le plus dans la vie le
bonheur ce que je vous plaît le moins
dans la vie non pas le malin ça va trop
loin
c'est trop loin la connerie quoi le plus
beau moment de votre vie vous avez eu
anthony oui un des plus beaux mais c'est
plus fort c'est plus fort le pire quand
elle à ceux qui restent à la maison pas
encore d'argent voire guinée a le pire
m'est pas encore arrivé
c'est bien j'ai de la chance oui ce qui
a tout changé dans votre vie
la rencontre avec alain on peut dire
plus que le yoga ce qui n'a rien changé
dans votre vie
elle ment divan ce votre plus belle
histoire d'amour
abbatiale ah oui oui marc marc bourrel
votre histoire d'allemands la plus
minable
bernard menez on peut le dire
[Applaudissements]
non ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
est bien bonne
à bagdad veut dire
c'est vrai ouais est ce que vous
détestez dans le sexe indifférence mais
ça n'arrive pas souvent
c'est dans cette séquence n'a pas voilà
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu